what is special about starting at an  elite business school and is it really  worth it during my time at University I  did study at some of the leading schools  at bucconi and Milan London School of  Economics insert at the same time I also  studied at a public university the  University of Munich and for me the  difference was not at all about the  content the content in Munich at this  public university was rather comparable  to what I experienced in these other  universities and the other schools what  is distinctive about these Elite schools  are rather the other students the other  participants and this is due to the  selection it is much more selective much  more difficult to get in and of course  then this leads to a really high caliber  Network relevant contacts that  potentially you can tap into such a  network throughout the course of your  career for years to come this way